c'est une question à plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros que nous vous avons
posé alors qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
cette
sommeil Mbappé c'est trois prochaines
années
0 peut-être il peut venir
venir se la somme brut cumulée que
pourrait toucher Kylian Mbappe en trois
ans de contrat au PSG d'après les
révélations du Parisien c'est tout
simplement le plus gros contrat de
l'histoire du sport 216 millions d'euros
plus une prime à la signature de 180
millions d'euros versés en trois fois
plus une autre prime de fidélité de près
de 240 millions d'euros là aussi en
trois fois si le contrat est honoré
l'attaquant toucherait désormais 72
millions bruts par an ça fait 2,7
millions net par mois après impôt c'est
2000 fois le SMIC et pour les plus
envieux sachez tout de même que la
pépite du PSG est également un très bon
contribuable à seulement 23 ans Kylian
Mbappe génère en moyenne pour les
caisses de l'État près de 170 millions
d'euros par an je crois qu'on n'a pas
fait mieux pour réimporter l'argent
qu'on donne sur le gaz et le pétrole au
kata pour le réinventer en France il en
faut des centaines de MBP en France
parce que pour 6 euros
qu'il coûte il y en a quatre qui
reviennent directement du Qatar dans les
caisses de l'État si j'étais cylique
j'irai mais bravo c'est le champion de
non pas de l'évasion fiscale mais de
l'invasion enfin du retour fiscal 210
millions par an pour le Mbappe c'est un
quart du budget du PSG mais le PSG a
démenti cet après-midi ouais le PSG a
démenti est préparé même une action
justice contre le journal Le Parisien et
de son côté Killian Mbappe lui n'a pas
réagi on peut le comprendre il peut pas
réagir à chaque fois qu'on parle de lui
allô oui oui
c'est rien passé on dit lui que ça ne se
fait jamais du premier coup richiste
Suna qui l'a 42 ans désignait
aujourd'hui à la tête du Parti
conservateur il sera nommé demain
Premier ministre du Royaume-Uni en
remplacement de lis Struss un petit-fils
d'immigré d'origine indienne il devient
le premier chef de gouvernement issu
d'une minorité à s'installer au 10
Downing
il est également le plus jeune et le
plus riche puisque sa fortune est
évaluée à plus de
840 millions d'euros elle est deux fois
plus élevé que celle du couple royal
actuel figure rassurante pour les
marchés financiers mais beaucoup moins
populaires auprès des classes moyennes
il avait notamment été moqué pour cette
vidéo dans laquelle il semble ne pas
savoir utiliser le paiement sans contact
ouais les gens ne savent pas comment ils
vont se chauffer ou se nourrir cet hiver
comment un multimillionnaire ou encore
sa femme pourrait compatir avec ce que
vivent les gens ont peut-être que vous
avez vécu dans un milieu
[Applaudissements]
j'étais trop baptisé
la première nuit elle était courte mais
excellente
qu'elle ressenti que tu as eu toi pareil
c'est top ça
bon bah profitez pour le café dehors
la première nuit avec Florence ça met en
route le programme feu d'artifice que
j'avais imaginé à part ça peu de gens se
le demande mais que devient Jean-Marie
Le Pen et bien il continue de tenir son
journal de bord sur Youtube et vous me
croirez ou non mais ce week-end il l'a
passé à la Fistinière visiblement quoi
c'est le bras oui c'est lundi finesse
dans c'est à vous
[Musique]
quand les éditorialistes
au lieu de parler tu drame
parle
de ma sortie et dise on est au Moyen-âge
et quand Eric Dupond-Moretti pour
Moretti prononce 4 fois mon nom dans
C'est à vous dans une émission pour dire
que c'est inadmissible ce qui est
inadmissible monsieur Dupont-Moretti
ce qui est inadmissible c'est que cette
personne est fait ça c'est pas ce que
j'ai dit qui est inadmissible c'est une
comme une double douleur d'avoir déjà
perdu son enfant et en plus d'avoir
ce cette phase ça on n'avait jamais eu
l'alerte incendie en direct je sais pas
quoi faire moi
je vais tenter peut-être mais qui sait
de lancer le fil info il se trouve que
le fil info se fait deux étages au
dessus peut-être qu'on échappera à
l'alarme incendie j'ai dit que cette
personne
qui a commis un acte inadmissible abject
ne doit avoir et doit avoir un procès
très rapide et avoir la perpétuité et là
tout le monde dit c'est inadmissible ce
qui a dit Cyril Hanouna écoutez-moi bien
vous êtes dit vous dites peut-être que
c'est inadmissible enfin pour moi ce qui
est inadmissible c'est de faire des
tweets et de faire des édito là dessus